so remember listening to an interview
that Larry King was doing and he was
talking about his very first show when I
believe it was a radio show and the
advice that somebody gave and was just
go on be yourself and be honest with the
audience and so he did he went on and he
told everybody hey my name is Larry King
this is my very first show i'm
super-nervous i'm probably gonna make a
lot of mistakes and he did make mistakes
and it wasn't a fantastic show but the
people who called in they supported him
and said hey Larry you're doing a great
job keep going we believe in you it was
really interesting for me because a lot
of times you know you try to put your
best foot forward you try to maybe seem
better than you are you wanna you want
people to think a certain way of you
we're often the best way to be is just
honest and authentic and it doesn't have
to be perfect every time people like to
take shots at what's perfect and if you
show some vulnerability and humanity
people are more likely to listen to your
message so that's a quick back story
this is a Christmas message I wanted to
make a really special Christmas video
and had all these big ideas and and none
of them kind of came to fruition and I
started running out of time then I
thought okay I'm not going to do any
video and I can we just do a regular
video not a Christmas video but I
thought you know like I really
appreciate you guys watching the
audience so I'm just gonna have a honest
heartfelt message and you know the past
year youtube has been such a huge area
of happiness for me it's part of my
daily routine every morning I wake up
when i look at your comments and you
guys are the fuel for me you guys keep
me excited and motivated and and
energetic and happy and and believing in
myself and and what we're trying to do
and I'm so grateful for all your
comments for all of your love for all of
your sharing I really mean that that's
that's coming from here and it's really
been one of the best parts of my
business and of my life for the past
year so I wanted to just send a Merry
Christmas message to thank you guys for
all your love and support I hope you
have a awesome christmas i hope you are
able to spend some time with your family
do something nice for somebody even if
it's a total stranger and take a little
bit of time recharge those batteries
because we're going to all have an
awesome 2015 and i will see you guys on
the other side thank you again so much
for your viewership your loyalty your
love Merry Christmas continue to believe
and I'll see you soon make sure to check
out my nose letter ya gotta laughing hi
I'm Jason j-rod fonseka of ra's online
com and i want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and it's the only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period